fragen wir jetzt nochmal in ruhe wie
familienfreundlich ist denn unsere
regierung in ihren wahlspots haben ja
spd und union ohne ende mit süßen
kindern geworben in der realität stellt
sich raus so kinderfreundlich ist
deutschland gar nicht wirklich kaputte
schulen fehlende betreuungsplätze selbst
geboren werden ist hier gar nicht so
einfach wir haben nämlich viel zu wenig
hebammen und die die wir haben werden
furchtbar mies bezahlt von ihrer
aufmerksamkeit hängt es oft genug ab ob
eine lebensbedrohliche situation erkannt
wird
dafür bekommt sie nicht mehr als eine
hilfsarbeiterin ohne ausbildung ja aber
gut meint wir was machen die auch schon
groß zur hebamme pressen pressen atmen
atmen flutscht spaß es ist unverschämt
wie die bezahlt werden und verstehen und
dann müssen freiberufliche hebammen auch
noch horrende berufshaftpflicht prämien
zahlen die haben sich zuletzt erhöht auf
7600 euro pro jahr und hebamme gibt sie
nicht meine herren
dann stellen sie sich mal eine sekunde
vor das passiert mit ihrer kfz
versicherung
[Musik]
o
sich anständigen gesichtern
ja
ja ich doch
ist doch kein wunder dass wir kaum noch
hebammen haben in deutschland und am
besten buchen sie auch ihren platz im
kreißsaal schon jahre vor der zeugung
sieben minuten fahrt mit dem
rettungswagen als sie dort ankommt ist
aufnahmestopp der kreißsaal überfüllt
auch noch irgendwann der spruch wir
können sie gerne ins klo schieben immer
noch besser als die pathologie oder so
läuft das in einem profitorientierten
gesundheitssystem da machen
krankenhäuser mit normalen geburten kein
geld mehr
immerhin lässt man sich mittlerweile was
einfallen um den hebammen mangel
auszugleichen
besonders einfallsreich diese klinik wo
werdende mamas das kind selber ganz
spielerisch auf die welt holen können
aber achtung unbedingt genug kleingeld
mitnehmen meine damen tatsächlich
schließen deutschlandweit immer mehr
geburtsstationen und kliniken es fakt
die initiative motherhood ev hat letzten
sommer ist kein spaß eine reisewarnung
für schwangere herausgegeben weil in
vielen teilen deutschlands vor allem im
süden einfach keine sichere geburtshilfe
mehr garantiert ist und weil auch das
mit der vereinbarkeit von familie und
beruf so viel schlechter läuft als in
anderen ländern ist das abenteuer
vermehrung einer der letzten echten
herausforderung
vergiss die klappen fischer aus alaska
lacht sich kaputt über ice road truckers
die richtig treffen budgets werden
mutter mindestens 18 jahre stress trifft
jahrelang nur andere mütter die genau so
depressiv sind wie du und rege
ausschließlich über kollegen bildungs
gymnastik kombiniere den stress eines
topmanagers beginnt gehalt eines friseur
azubis aus sachsen und das geilste du
kannst nicht mal kündigen
bock mutter denn einmal wussten es ja
machen
[Applaus]